By the very nature, transactions are distributed
at each node, and the transaction manager is
responsible for all the clients over interactions that
touches that particular node. For example, the client
at this node could have done the following,
he could have opened the window for reading
Gmail. It could of opened a window in
which is accessing file for editing,. Now the
transaction manager node A, has to manage
the transaction keys corresponding to each of the
client server interactions, that is initiated by
this client. Opening a window for Gmail is
one interaction. Opening another window. Which is
accessing a file for everything with another interaction.
The transaction manager is responsible for maintaining the
transaction trees for each one of those separately.
And the transaction manager where the client
server interaction originates. Is the owner as
well as the coordinator. But it is designatable to some of the node as I
mentioned already. And there is a graph
structure for the transaction tree. And this is
very useful in terms of reducing network
communication because all the transaction manages. That form
this interaction, don't have to always communicate
with the coordinator. For instance, the transaction managers
at nodes C and D, have been contacted because of IPC that originated at node B,
to node C and D respectively. In that case, they only have to report To node
B and they don't have to necessarily report
to coordinator of the whole transaction sheet. So,
this is helpful in reducing the amount of network
communication. All transaction managers are not equal. I mentioned
earlier that Brittle nodes in the system are the
client nodes, and therefore, it is possible that a transaction
manager, that originated at a client node may designate
the coordinator to be a more robust node like
the file server. And there are different kind of
failures that can happen. There could be a failure of
a participant node In the transaction. Or there
could be a connection failure. Or it is
possible that one of the subordinate transaction manager
failed to report. All of these are sources
of failure. Now, one of the things that
the transaction manager at each node has to
do, is to log periodically to persistent store,
state that is created on behalf of the client.
Or on behalf of the server whatever is happening at that node this transaction
manager is responsible for creating checkpoint records
for recovability reasons. And these checkpoint records
will be useful for warding off against failures or partial recovery of work. So
the distributed system failures can happen at
any point. If for instance this node fails,
then the transaction manager of this node has
also failed, and this is something that this transaction
manager is going to find out about because it doesn't
hear any response from this transaction manager, but a
transaction represented by this graph here, is not
aborted at the first indication of failure of a
node. And the reason is because you don't want
error reporting to stop as a result of failure.
You want the transaction to be aborted only
upon termination as requested by the transaction manager,
the coordinator of the transaction tree. And the
reason is as I said, is to make sure
that partial failures,they may have left states. You
want to clean up all of that, and
that will happen when a coordinator initiates termination
of the transaction. We'll see that in a minute.